bonjour c'est le retour des gentes dames
badass et pour coller aux derniers
chronique de profs sur les mers on va
parler d'une femme qui les a parcouru
les mers j'ai déjà parlé de jeanne de
belleville une pirate du 14e siècle et
de anna maria mérian qui était une
naturalistes du xviiie siècle jeanne
paraît dont on va parler aujourd'hui
rassemble à la fois le fait d'être une
femme qui dit merde aux conventions de
son époque et de se passionner pour le
naturalisme et puis pour une fois qu'on
sait beaucoup de choses sur une femme
qui n'est absolument pas issu de la
noblesse pas se priver de parler d'elle
jeanne est née le 27 juillet 1740 près
d'autun en bourgogne
son père était journaliste c'est à dire
un paysan sans terre qui faisait un peu
tous les travaux des champs qu'ils
pouvaient ils étaient aussi probablement
analphabètes sa mère était femme au
foyer
probablement un peu nourrissent à ses
heures est probablement occupé par tous
les petits travaux qui pouvait lui
permettre de nourrir la famille en
grandissant dans une famille paysanne du
xviiie siècle dans une des régions les
plus pauvres de france à cette époque
n'a pas dû avoir une enfance très facile
on sait assez peu de choses sur sa
jeunesse elle apprend à lire et à écrire
et commence à travailler à ces jeunes
comme gouvernante si elle perd ses
parents jeunes aussi on sait pas trop
comment
de là elle part à paris pour travailler
comme gouvernante encore une fois mais
elle perd un procès contre l'un de ses
employeurs ce qui la ruine du peu
d'argent qu'elle avait et c'est
seulement en 1764 qu'elle est engagée
comme gouvernante par philibert
commerson là on va un peu s'arrêter sur
philibert commerson puisque c'est le
personnage le plus important de sa vie
philibert et médecins mais surtout
passionné de botanique
il tient d'état derbier et passe ses
journées à courir la campagne
charolaises à la recherche de nouvelles
espèces accueillir sa femme est morte en
couches deux ans plus tôt et il appelle
donc jeanne au secours pour qu'elle
s'occupe de son fils
rapidement elle devient plus qu'une
simple gouvernante parce qu'elles se
passionnent pour la botanique
elle lit les herbiers les livres de
commerson et lui donne des cours sur ces
différentes choses et elle est dans ces
travaux elle répertorie ces documents
les plans qui ramasse et l'aide à
constituer ces herbiers et rapidement
ils deviennent aussi probablement avant
la sphère commence à savoir à la fin de
l'année 1764 puisqu'elle tombe enceinte
et alors là c'est le scandale au village
elle refuse de dire qui est le terme si
c'est probablement philibert et
finissent par partir à paris pour faire
taire le scandale le fils de philibert
est alors confiée à un oncle et on en
entendra plus parler de son côté jane
accouche d'un garçon qui plaçait à
l'assistance publique
il ne vit que quelques mois de toute
façon ça faisait un moment que philibert
voulait monter à la capitale pour
commencer à se faire connaître
là il rencontre d'autres botanique des
scientifiques et notamment un astronome
qui leurs commandes auprès du roi c'est
grâce à ça qu'on lui propose en 1766 de
participer à l'expédition de
bougainville et c'est là que nous allons
faire un point gauguin ville gauguin
viel est un officier de marine mais
aussi très intéressé par la géographie
il sort tout juste de la guerre de sept
ans pendant laquelle la france a perdu
le canada ce qui n'est pas une mince
affaire
il avait bien réussi à conquérir les
malouines pour le roi mais elles sont
finalement cédé aux anglais il est donc
un peu déçu et convainc le roi de
financer cette expédition
déjà parce que lui doit bien ça et aussi
parce que ça serait la première
expédition française autour du monde ce
qui en jetterait face aux anglais
l'expédition a donc surtout un but
politique diplomatique et scientifique
à l'époque on ne pense pas encore
beaucoup à la colonisation ça viendra
ensuite
et aussi grâce aux idées des lumières
qui circulent à cette époque les
explorateurs se montre assez respectueux
et curieux des populations qu'ils
rencontrent contrairement au siècle
suivant
c'est aussi une époque pendant laquelle
on s'intéresse énormément aux sciences
bref commerçants hésitent à partir parce
qu'il a une santé fragile il se ferait
bien accompagné par jane sauf que les
femmes sont interdites à bord des
navires du roi il accepte finalement et
par embarquer à bord de l'étoile qui
doit aller rejoindre bougainville en
amérique du sud est là mais qui apparaît
donc jean bart est un homme assez mince
imberbe qui se présente comme le valais
payé par le roi pour assister commerson
et puis comme commerce on a mal de mer
ils demandent à ce que son valet dorment
dans sa cabine
au cas où il a de la chance d'avoir une
cabine rien que pour lui pour entreposer
ces herbiers avec toilettes privées ce
qui est bien pratique pour son valet si
vous n'aviez pas encore compris jean
barrès et jeanne mais qui à cacher sa
poitrine et qui s'est déguisée en homme
d'où le fait que je porte une perruque
aujourd'hui le 1er février 1767
le voyage commence et pour que vous
comprenez bien à quel point jeanne et
philibert joue un jeu dangereux s'ils
étaient découverts ces surtout philibert
qui risquerait gros la bastille en fait
parce que jeanne étant une femme
considère qu'elle n'est pas vraiment
responsable de ses actes la pauvre
philibert en revanche aurait pu être
accusé d'avoir embarqué une femme à bord
pour son bon plaisir ça c'est grave
à la même époque l'explorateur kerguelen
qui a découvert les il dit
non pas qu'elles coïncident ans a été
condamné à six ans de forteresse pour
avoir embarqué sa maîtresse de 14 ans à
bord déguisé en valet de chambre
jeanne n'est pas vraiment dans la même
situation puisqu'elle est surtout là
pour l'assister dans ses travaux la
surnomme même sa bête de somme
sympa mais on sait grâce au testament de
philibert qu'elle était payée pour ça le
voyage ne commence pas très bien puisque
dès les premiers jours le navire prend
l'eau
il faut pomper régulièrement de son côté
philibert a le mal de mer mais
l'équipage arrive quand même à rejoindre
les côtes du brésil puis rio de janeiro
où les attentes bouquin ville avec son
propre navire là ils font escale un mois
ce qui permet à jeanne et philibert
d'explorer la ville et ses environs
et c'est un sacré choc culturel pour
jeanne parce qu'elle a connu que la
france donc elle découvre le café et le
sucre
et c'est là aussi qu'ils commencent à
ramasser d'état plantes dont le boudin
villiers que philibert nomme en
l'honneur de bougainville à bord du
navire se trouve aussi françois vives et
qui était chirurgien et qui a tenu un
journal de bord dans lequel on retrouve
souvent des informations sur jeanne
c'est grâce à lui en partie qu'on a des
infos sur l aujourd'hui elle à l'ergot
risée avec son maître dans les plaines
des montagnes armé d'un fusil et de
papier pour les plantes
après rio et le reprennent leur route
vers le sud pour atteindre le détroit de
magellan mais sont obligés de
s'immobiliser deux mois dans
l'embouchure de la plata à cause du
navire qui prend toujours l'eau là
beaucoup de marins souffrent de
diarrhées à cause de l'eau du fleuve qui
est pas très bonne est une vieille
blessure de philibert se rouvrent aussi
mais ça ne les empêche pas d'aller
arborisé tous les jours d'après le
journal de philibert chaque pas que je
faisais était payé d'une découverte ou
d'une observation est essentielle
ils reprennent enfin la route et met
encore deux mois à traverser le détroit
de magellan puis trois mois à traverser
le pacifique vers tahiti
pendant ce temps la janais philibert
catalogue et trie les spécimens qu'ils
ont récoltées tout le long de la côte
brésilienne
enfin que jeanne a récolté surtout parce
qu'à cause de la blessure de philibert
il passait la plupart de son temps à
bord du navire
l'arrivée à tahiti et décisif puisque
c'est là d'après le journal de
bougainville que l'identité de jeanne et
découverte pour honorer les visiteurs
les tahitiens leur offre de s'unir aux
jeunes filles locales
philibert trouve ça génial est décrit
dans son journal que tahiti l'île de
l'amour bla bla bla et jeanne est
beaucoup plus mesuré et choquée par ce
qu'elle voit bien que les jeunes filles
ne sont pas vraiment d'accord avec ce
qui se passe en tout cas d'après bouquin
ville
un pâtissier a nommé out our ou déclare
immédiatement que c'est une femme et
aimerait bien en profiter si vous voyez
ce que je veux dire là forcément
bougainville est informé du problème la
vérité et découvertes même si jeanne
prétend avoir tout manigancé sans que
philibert et découvert la vérité ce qui
est peu probable
cet épisode a probablement bien eu lieu
mais l'identité de jeanne avait sûrement
été découvertes depuis longtemps déjà
en racontant que jeanne a été découverte
par les tahitiens bougainville se
protègent un petit peu contre les
poursuites qu'ils pourraient subir tous
les autres témoignages des différents
journaux de bord montre que jeanne était
soupçonné d'être une femme depuis bien
plus longtemps
dès les canaris apparemment l'équipage
commencé à douter d'elle et donc à lui
attribuer tous les malheurs à bord dont
le journal de bord de françois vives et
on trouve différentes notes sur elle
après les premiers mois un petit murmure
s'éleva dans l'équipage sur ce qu'il y
avait à bord une fille déguisée
on trouve étrange qu'elle ait des
petites mains pas de poils au menton et
elle essaye de faire taire les rumeurs
en d'abord faisant croire qu'elle était
un eunuque puis en se mettant à dormir
dans un mac avec le reste de l'équipage
participer aux manoeuvres
mais il est probable que l'équipage a
soupçonné depuis longtemps voire même
qu'elle était ouvertement découverte
on ne sait pas par contre si
bougainville était au courant pendant
tout ce temps puisqu'il était dans deux
navires différents
en tout cas après cette révélation et en
dépit des risques que ça comporte pour
l'expédition bougainville autorise
jeanne a continué le voyage
habillée en homme est arrêté de se
bander la poitrine l'équipage explora
lors la nouvelle guinée et atteint l'île
maurice en 1768 là j'en ai philibert
débarque pour passer plus de temps à
explorer de lille avec un ami botaniste
qui étaient déjà sur place et sûrement
aussi parce que les la santé de
philibert et plus en plus mauvaises sur
cette île et donne le nom de bar et à
une plante en l'honneur de jeanne mais
elle est renommée par les naturalistes
français peu de temps après ils passent
encore cinq ans ensemble à botany zélés
île des environs et vont probablement
ensemble à madagascar et sur l'île
bourbon l'actuelle réunion mais
philibert meurt finalement le 13 mars
ironiquement il est nommé associé de
l'académie des sciences six semaines
après sa mort ce qui était un petit peu
son rêve et on ne connaît pas
l'emplacement de sa tombe mais on sait
qu'il avait rédigé un testament avant
d'entreprendre ce voyage il lève la
plupart de ses biens à son fils mais
accorde 600 livres et son appartement à
jeanne et lui demande aussi en cas de
décès de mettre en ordre ses collections
et les envoyer au roi ce qui prouve bien
qu'il estimait beaucoup le travail du
botaniste
de jeanne elle expédie donc en france 32
caisses qui contiennent 5 mille plantes
séchées dont 3000 nouvelles
malheureusement le tout est assez
dispersées philibert n'était pas un
scientifique très rigoureux et une
partie des caisses va au muséum notre
parti va au naturaliste buffon encore
d'autres caisses à d'autres botaniste
jeanne ne peut pas embarquer avec les
caisses parce qu'elle n'a pas d'argent
et parce que pour rentrer en france il
faudrait qu'elle se fasse à nouveau
passer pour un homme comme elle est
seule et qu'elle ne peut pas toucher
l'argent du testament avant de rentrer
en france
elle décide d'ouvrir une auberge une
bonne auberge là elle rencontre un
officier de marine jean dubernat qu'elle
épouse en 1774 et avec lequel elle
rentre en france
enfin un an plus tard ce qui fait d'elle
la première femme à avoir fait le tour
du monde
là elle termine ces jours dans le
périgord avec son mari mais ne tombent
pas dans l'oubli pour autant en 1776
elle reçoit l'argent de son héritage et
à partir de 1785 elle reçoit 200 livres
annuelles de la part de louis saez
lui-même qui la félicite pour ses
talents date botaniste et aussi pour
avoir partagé avec le plus grand courage
les travaux et périls de commerçants
pour rappel louis saez qualifie donc de
femme extraordinaire une femme issue de
la paysannerie la plus modeste qui s'est
travesti illégalement pour embarquer sur
un de ses navires
le tout pour devenir botaniste si ça
c'est pas la classe
elle meurt finalement le 5 août 1807 à
saint-omer même si elle a longtemps été
oublié une plante grimpante a été nommé
solano mme barrette ya en son honneur en
2002 plusieurs livres d'histoire aux
romands ont été écrit à son sujet et une
chaîne de montagnes est nommé montbard
et en son honneur une chaîne de montagne
sur pluton ce qui la rend exceptionnel
ça n'est donc pas le fait qu'elle se
soit travesti pour braver un interdit
puis ça a été pas la première femme à
faire ça ni son histoire d'amour avec
commerson parce que ça n'avait pas non
plus l'air d'être le grand amour entre
eux il semblerait que ce soit plutôt une
association de botanistes et plus si
affinités elle n'est pas non plus
décrites comme particulièrement belle
dans les différents témoignages sur el
bounadi lundi par exemple n est ni lait
ni jolie et elle n'a pas 25 ans elle
faisait attention à ne jamais changer de
linge ni faire aucune nécessité devant
qui que ce soit elle a eu la chance de
devenir la gouvernante de philibert
commerson d'abord ce qui lui a permis de
se hisser au dessus de sa condition
sociale
le reste ce qui fait que je l apprécie
vient uniquement de son caractère
elle fait preuve de curiosité et elle
rêve de partir à l'aventuré dès que
l'occasion se présente malgré les
risques que ça comporte auprès de
philibert elle apprend la botanique mais
aussi l'anatomie par exemple en
disséquant des poissons et tout ça fait
qu'elle est qualifiée d' experts en
botanique par hbo guerville lui-même
c'était une scientifique à une époque où
elles étaient encore rares et la
première femme à avoir fait le tour du
monde
j'espère que ce nouveau gentes dames
badass vous a plu n'hésitez pas à le
partager si c'est le cas pour ce qui est
des prochaines vidéos qui sortiront bien
il ya le prochain chronique de profs qui
sera la partie 2 sur la mer toujours
avec les tas de choses inédites dont je
n'ai pas parlé dans la partie une ce qui
est plutôt logique
enfin est également le court métrage
star wars que j'ai filmé entre juin et
juillet et qui devrait pas tarder à
sortir normalement après ça et bien
chronique de profs se succéderont comme
d'habitude on va essayer de tenir le
rythme de un par mois
et time warp avance toujours et je vous
donnerai une date de sortie
un jour on termine de tourner la série
fin août et après ça il m'a il va y
avoir un montage postproduction et c'est
donc ça va prendre encore un petit peu
de temps avant qu'on puisse se sortir je
pense sûrement ma vie vers le groupe
décembre comme on l'avait annoncé dans
les premières vidéos
en attendant donc passez une bonne fin
d'été et vous pouvez toujours aller sur
typique et your type pour financer mes
vidéos
ce qui fait plaisir voilà au revoir
[Musique]